another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the foundation dr  bright is not allowed to speed date if  you remember an event called scp speed  dating please report to site command  immediately for your mandatory dose of  class a amnestic this event never  officially took place and there was no  public record of it dr bright certainly  did not pack the canteen with safe class  humanoid as cps and employees of the  foundation and ding a bell every five  minutes so that eligible singles could  switch tables and meet someone new there  were no public displays of affection on  foundation grounds and certainly no  ensuing disastrous dates at any local  italian restaurants dr bright is not  allowed to organize a speed dating event  ever again  um  i mean for for the first time because  there has never been one not here  no sir